oui bonjour Avez-vous vu Mathieu
croissant
à tous salut Julien bonjour je sors de
chez le dentiste
de nous tenir au courant de notre vie
privée et puis le journaliste et
écrivain bien sûr Fred Hermel ça lui
Fred bonjour et moi je sors du métro
voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver il fait froid
vous êtes bien français
à l'eau sur cette plage près de Lorient
je pense que aujourd'hui elle est à 20
peut-être même plus elle devrait être à
18 voir en dessous habituellement les
autres années c'est pas comme on se
baignent pas aussi facilement
qu'aujourd'hui un phénomène qui se
ressent dans tout l'Atlantique nord
jusqu'à 5 degrés de plus que la moyenne
sur certaines zones les scientifiques
parlent même de canicule marie à la
longue cela pourrait avoir des
conséquences en premier lieu sur la vie
aquatique l'été dernier la Méditerranée
a elle aussi été frappée par une
canicule marine cet événement a
bouleversé par endroits certains
écosystèmes l'impact a été localisé sur
certaines populations notamment
d'invertébrés de Gorgone de corail
d'éponges mais attention il y a
certaines espèces qui ont bénéficié de
ça notamment l'airbncidonie qui est une
floraison exceptionnelle dans son
scénario le plus pessimiste le GIEC
prévoit une multiplication par 50 de ses
canicules océaniques d'ici la fin du
siècle bah oui mais oui
bah oui
au nom de l'écologie radicale faut
arrêter maintenant donner le son à la
terre entière après après Marion
Cotillard elle avait soudé quand même de
vrais problèmes sur le 11 septembre sur
Coluche elle avait dit elle était pas
sûr et puis elle allait me dit elle se
demandait si l'homme avait vraiment
marché sur la Lune j'ai pas mal de
documentaire là-dessus et ça c'est
vraiment je m'intéresse en tout cas je
ne crois pas tout ce qu'on me dit ça
c'est sûr faut-il croire tout ce que dit
sa tête se trouve l'araignée mais à mon
avis elle n'a pas trouvé bon ok
je connais l'une des deux personnes je
bonsoir bonsoir je me permets
d'embrasser quand même ça va
déjà bienvenue à Jean-Luc Reichmann
salut bonsoir Nagui qu'est-ce qui se
passe il faut pas pleurer je vous assure
oui je sais il y a une odeur bizarre
mais c'est normal faut pas pleurer je
sais rencontre insolito beau milieu de
l'océan capté par un droniste
tu sais qu'il y a une baleine qui est en
train de te suivre elle est vraiment
très proche à travers les autres
translucides il filme ce cétacé qui
s'approche de ce kayakiste je ne pense
pas qu'il le sache seulement quelques
mètres d'écart les séparent
toi elle est en dessous de toi nous
sommes en train de tourner sur le
plateau mitoyen je sais vous êtes juste
à côté absolument
et dans le public et je lui dis vous
allez bien oui ça va très bien elle
accompagne un lycée agricole dans
l'Aisne et qui a rien dit mais vous avez
déjà assisté à une émission de télé elle
dit non c'est la première fois et je lui
dis mais vous connaissez votre émission
oui dans les douze coups de midi et elle
dit non je ne connais pas du tout votre
émission en revanche je suis fan de
N'oubliez pas les paroles c'était pas
forcément notre tasse de thé trois cafés
gourmands annoncent oui j'attends je
réfléchis encore à ta blague à oui c'est
dans le journal Le Parisien que le
groupe originaire de Corrèze la annoncé
donc 10 ans d'existence pendant trois
kilomètres
l'étonnant du haut va partager côte à
côte le même terrain de jeu ces eaux
turquoises
c'est incroyable
le grandiose face à face s'est déroulé
au large de Sidney ce week-end
à préciser que c'est grâce à Nagui que
je suis devenu aujourd'hui ou que je
suis pas du tout je suis tu m'as laissé
la porte ouverte le micro j'ai laissé la
porte ouverte
et j'ai fait attention à toutes les
marches bien évidemment en tous les cas
voilà merci
alors on y va attention parce que je
suis fan de l'émission et donc par amour
pour Babeth je vais vous apprendre à
faire allez vous prendre une baie vitrée
non
[Rires]
non non on est sur le coup l'idée c'est
qu'il faut être en train de parler il
faut être en train de dire oui parce que
effectivement
que diriez-vous de passer vos vacances
dans la maison de Barbie je vous sens
bien vous maquillage
vous voulez
pas un petit bisou magique
des bisous tout doux
et je vais faire un câlin magique à
Jean-Michel vous allez voir attention
Jean-Michel vous êtes prêts câlin
magique regardez
ses bras
il me parle tout bas
je vois la vie en rose
oh là là
il y a de quoi s'amuser en totalement
sur place des toboggans piscine piste de
danse pour vous Thomas pour vous
déhancher si vous le souhaitez en
revanche pas de cours de tennis alors
Julia je vois que vous aimez beaucoup le
décor ça vous donne peut-être des idées
pour vous alors la location sera
possible à partir du 21 juillet c'est la
date de 21 juillet date de sortie
allez donne-moi le bébé
[Musique]
j'arrive
allez maman elle va arriver t'inquiète
le 21 juillet c'est la date de sortie du
film Barbie aux États-Unis et donc ce
jour là 7h08
a demandé à Julia pourquoi vous voulez
Ken et vous ajoutez
une citation